hi everyone so today I'm going to talk
to you about some of our work on
simultaneous discovery of coordinates
and parsimonious dynamics so traditional
methods for modeling physical systems
involved deriving governing equations
from first principles or universal laws
such as conservation laws or gravity as
an example I can show you this video of
a pendulum here now we can easily derive
a simple equation for describing the
behavior that is seen in this video the
behavior of the pendulum with a one
equation in a single variable that is
the angular position of the pendulum and
we can just do this using Newtonian
mechanics a more interesting example is
the navier-stokes equations the navier
stokes equations are also derived using
first principles conservation of mass
energy and momentum and they're written
down here the navier-stokes equations
are widely used for modeling fluid flows
and they're used in applications such as
climate modeling and engineering of cart
design of cars and airplanes however
there are many systems for which we do
not have a known set of governing
equations for example this video here
shows activity in a mass brain we don't
have a clear known set of governing
equations that describes the overall
activity seen in the brain and deriving
such an equation from first principles
has proven very challenging so this
motivates methods for discovering such
governing equations from data and
particularly from high dimensional data
sets that are now becoming more readily
available such as this one so today I'm
going to focus on the goal of turning
high dimensional scientific data into
parsimonious dynamical models so as an
example again we can consider the
pendulum so here I have high dimensional
data in the form of this video of the
pendulum behaving
and the goal would be to discover a low
dimensional parsimonious dynamical model
that is the pendulum equation from this
video so in order to do this we need to
be able to identify both the coordinates
in which two the dynamics become simple
and then we also need to be able to
identify the dynamics so you need to be
able to pull out that the angular
position of the pendulum is the right
variable in which to represent the
dynamics simply so the method I'm going
to talk about today performs a
simultaneous discovery using an
autoencoder
to identify the coordinates and cyndi to
model the dynamics so to start telling
you about our method I'm going to start
with an overview of Cindy so Cindy is
the method introduced in 2016 this is
the sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics so for Cindy we assume that we
have measurements of some data X and we
have snapshot measurements of this data
in time so these are your state
variables of whatever system you're
interested in and we just assume this is
a vector in RN and you have snapshots
collected over time we assume that this
data X was generated from some
underlying dynamical system in the form
seen here so we have some function f
which describes the dynamics the idea of
Cindy is that we don't necessarily know
F and we want to discover it from
measurements of X so as an example we
can just consider the canonical Lorenz
system seen here so here we have a set
of three equations so this is a state
variable in three dimensions and this
set of functions on the right hand side
here make up our F that describe the
dynamics and then we can see the
dynamics they
this plot here so the goal here would be
to take measurements on this attractor
and discover the form of F that
generated this data so Cindy is based on
the observation that for many physical
systems of interest this function f is
actually sparse in the basis of possible
functions so for many physical equations
that were interested in we only have
relatively few terms in this function f
for example when we're looking at this
Lorenz system here even if we only
consider a basis of polynomials of your
state variables up to cubics there's
still relatively few terms in the
dynamics in this equation so Cindy sets
up the problem of discovering the
underlying equations as a sparse
regression among a library of possible
terms in your function f so now I'm just
going to show you a real quick walk
through of how Cindy works so we assume
we have some set of measurements that
come from some underlying unknown true
system such as our Lorenz system here so
we take derivatives we either measure
the derivatives or assume we can
calculate them from our snapshot
measurements of X and then we stack
these time derivatives into a matrix so
here in this matrix each column is a
time derivative of a different state
variable and each row is a measurement
or calculation of the derivative at a
different time we then create a library
of possible candidate functions that are
going to be in our underlying dynamical
system so here I've just enumerated
functions and the state variables these
are polynomials up to cubics and again
each row in this matrix is going to be a
measurement at a certain time point and
each column here is going to be a
candidate function in the in the
underlying dynamics
so Cindy then performs a sparse
regression to identify the terms in the
dynamical system of interest
so here I've highlighted the terms in
this Lorenz dynamical system so you can
see that even in this very limited basis
the true underlying system is indeed
sparse so from this we now get an
identified system and we hope that the
system we identified has a close match
for our true I know mix so Cindy works
well if we know the right set of state
variables to measure so in this Lorenz
system that I showed you here I told you
what the seat variables are and we can
easily write down a set of equations
that govern the dynamics in this set of
variables however from any real-world
systems we don't actually know what
variables to measure we don't know what
variables are responsible for describing
the true underlying dynamics that are
seen and this is particularly true for
high dimensional data sets so many data
sets these days are specifically high
dimensional and for example a lot of
them will have measurements at different
spatial locations or we might have high
dimensional video data so here I'm
showing a video video of the pendulum as
well as a spatial representation of a
PDE so this is a simulation of a
reaction diffusion system and in systems
like this if we just are given this high
dimensional data we don't necessarily
know which coordinates are right to
represent the dynamics that are going on
in this high dimensional data so this
motivates in combining some sort of
method for discovering coordinates with
Cindy so one particular thing you might
think about doing is just applying a
standard dimensionality reduction method
to these high dimensional data sets in
order to get a simple set of variables
and then you could try to form a Sindhi
model on that representation that comes
out however this
can potentially have limitations so if
you just apply a standard out-of-the-box
dimensionality reduction method you
don't necessarily know that the
coordinates are the right coordinates to
find a simple dynamical system so this
is why we want to perform a joint
discovery of the coordinates and the
dynamics so today I'm going to talk
about a method we've developed for doing
that in particular in particular the
method we introduced uses auto-encoders
for discovering reduced coordinates so
I'm going to start talking to you about
autoencoders so an autoencoder is
essentially just a simple feed-forward
neural network but rather than training
it to do some tasks such as
classification or prediction you train
it to reproduce its input as its output
and then you the goal is to identify
some set of intrinsic coordinates or
latent code that hopefully tells you
something interesting about your data so
you can see the loss function for the
auto encoder down here if I'm giving it
some high dimensional input data X I
simply want the auto encoder to
reproduce be able to reproduce that data
and then I'm going to map through this
hidden layer that represents the
intrinsic coordinates and gives me some
alternative representation of my data so
one common use for auto-encoders is for
performing a dimensionality reduction
and that is the specific task I'm going
to talk about today so in order to get
an auto encoder to perform a
dimensionality reduction we simply
specify that the hidden layer in the
middle of the network has many fewer
units than the original input data and
so in this way you're training the auto
encoder to essentially find some low
dimensional representation of your data
that it can then use to recreate to be
original the data in its original form
so we're interested in finding reduced
coordinates along with dynamics so the
idea freezing an auto encoder here is to
essentially combine the
- encoder with a Sindhi model on the
reduced coordinates so in this way you
are essentially learning with the auto
encoder a reduced representation of your
data and then you're learning an
Associated Sindhi model in that reduced
space so you can combine these we have
the loss function for the auto encoder
shown over there and then the lost
function for the Sindhi model here and
we see that the last function for the
cindy model in this case is just written
in the z coordinates the intrinsic
coordinates of the auto encoder so now
we have the question of how do we do
this training so one way you could think
to try to find such a model is to
perform some sort of sequential training
so you could try to train an auto
encoder to find a reduced representation
of your data and then fit a Sindhi model
on the intrinsic coordinates that come
out of this auto encoder unfortunately
this has the same issue I mentioned with
using standard dimensionality reduction
approaches is that the auto encoder when
it's finding this reduced representation
does not know that you're interested in
a dynamical model and so the latent
coordinates that it finds might not be
well suited to finding a sparse simple
dynamical model so instead what we do is
we perform a simultaneous training to
learn both the reduced coordinates and
the Sindhi model at the same time so
essentially what we're interested in
doing is in addition to training the
weights in the auto encoder Network we
want to train we want to learn this set
of coefficients that are describe the
dynamical model so what we can do to do
this is essentially we can rewrite the
the terms in the cindy loss function
using the auto encoder weights and then
this coefficient matrix that you'll also
learn and then we can perform one
training of the network and the sydney
model so here you see we can rewrite the
derivatives in terms of the gradients of
the encoder and then we can
similarly rewrite the library functions
in terms of the weights of the network
and then this just gives us a combined
loss function shown here which is
rewritten in terms of the encoder
weights and coefficient matrix and then
we can use this together to train the
network and I'll also add in an l1
penalty here just to encourage that
we're finding a sparse dynamical model
and not just any dynamical model on the
data so this is the essential
essentially the setup that we use to
train our network so here we have one
term in the loss function that is used
to Train the auto encoder and ensure
that it's able to reconstruct our
original data using this reduced
representation and then we have a Sindhi
component here that ensures that we have
a good dynamical model a good dynamical
representation and the latent space okay
so now I'm just going to talk about how
we actually train our network and go
over a few examples so today I'm going
to talk about three example systems that
we've considered the first is sort of a
proof of concept example where we use
this original Lorenz system I introduced
earlier and we map it up to a high
dimensional data set just to see if the
network can recover this model from the
high dimensional data set that we start
with the next shows a rediscovery of a
reduced order model for a PDE so we'll
use a simple reaction diffusion system
and then the third case is trying to
discover a physics model from video so
here again I'll use the example of the
pendulum so I want to highlight that
when we're performing this training and
analyzing the results the thing that we
are most interested in is the sparsity
pattern of the resulting model so when I
talk about the examples we look at today
the main thing I'm going to focus on
does the network recover this varsity
pattern or this right coefficient matrix
for the cindy model are we able to find
the right form of the dynamics so with
that in mind we're going to look at the
sparsity pattern of the resulting models
for all of these example cases so one
thing I wanted to mention is that I
mentioned using an l1 penalty on the
coefficient matrix in order to actually
find sparse models however we found that
in our initial experimentation if we use
simply an l1 penalty alone this resulted
in models that had many coefficients
that were close to zero but weren't
truly sparse there weren't actually only
a few nonzero terms and for finding the
right sparsity pattern were really
interested in a mask that tells us like
these are the relevant terms in the
dynamics so in order to achieve this we
use an additional method inner training
so we did an additional step called
sequential thresholding so here I have
our loss function shown here so we use
this loss function to train and
encourage getting a Sindhi model with
many coefficients that are close to zero
but in addition we perform sequential
threshold ding which means that
essentially at fixed periods throughout
the training we so we specify some
threshold and then at fixed periods
throughout the training we just set
everything below that threshold to zero
so this gives us a way of kind of
sequentially masking out the non
relevant terms in the dynamics and in
the end this results in a truly sparse
dynamical model ok so now I will go over
the examples that I have mentioned so as
I mentioned the first example we look at
is sort of a proof-of-concept example
based on the law
so here we want to know if we have some
low dimensional dynamics and we map this
up to some high dimensional to high
dimensional spatial modes can we recover
the original low dimensional dynamics
so this Lorenz system on the left here
that I mentioned earlier is a set of
dynamic is a dynamical system in three
variables so we're interested in if we
take Heidemann like modes that are meant
to be spatial modes that are at a high
dimensional on a high dimensional grid
can we recover this simple three
dimensional system from the high
dimensional data so we take a set of
fixed spatial modes and then we just
generate new high dimensional data in in
this case we do it in 128 dimensions and
then we try to recover the original
Lorenz dynamics from this high
dimensional data so here I'm just
showing you a representation of the true
Lorenz model so these are the three
representations we're gonna look at we
have this set of true equations up here
this is the Sindhi coefficient matrix
and then this is just a picture of the
attractor so when we use our combined
Sindhi auto-encoder
this is the model that the training
procedure finds so these are the
equations again up top
this is the sparsity pattern from cindy
and then this is the attractor so a few
things I'll point out here one is
obviously these equations and this
coefficient matrix are not the same as
the original model however we do see
that the coefficient matrix still has
the same number of terms in the dynamics
and it looks somewhat similar to the
original coefficient matrix also the
attractor clearly does not look like the
original attractor however you can still
see that there's a two lobe structure to
the attractor so what we found out by
playing with this discovered system a
little bit is that actually you can find
an affine transformation on this
discovered model that gets you to the
original Lorenz
so here I'm just showing a system that
is an affine transformation of this
discovered model and you can see in this
case that the equations are very similar
match with the one exception being the
coefficient on these Z 1 Z 3 and Z 1 Z 2
terms which has a different magnitude
than in the original system but this is
just kind of an arbitrary scaling now
the coefficient pattern matches and the
attractor looks very similar to the
attractor for the original system so it
appears that this method was able to
discover a model that is essentially the
true Lorenz model so the next example
I'm going to talk about is based on a
simple reaction diffusion system so we
wanted to show an example to see if
given high dimensional spatial data from
a PDE we could discover a reduced order
model for the PDE so in this case we're
working with a reaction diffusion system
that just has a simple spiral we've
shown here and this video the activity
in this video can be well captured by
just a set of two oscillating modes so
we wanted to see essentially could the
auto encoder discover a simple
oscillating model for this this data or
what would it discover so we train the
model 2 or the network to discover a
reduced model with to intrinsic
coordinates and this is one of the
models that popped out of our cindy auto
encoder so you can see here from the
equations that it discovered a model
that was essentially just a simple
linear oscillation this is a
representation of the cindy coefficient
matrix so you can see obviously with two
terms this is a sparse model and then
this is just the attractor in the
reduced space it also in some cases
discovered this a nonlinear oscillation
so in in this case we included a sine
term in the library of possible
functions and in some cases the network
found that using the
find term in the oscillation also
provided a good representation of the
dynamic so this is a very similar system
and here again we show the retractor and
the reduced space right here all right
so the final example that we wanted to
consider was the idea of could we
discover a physics model from video data
so in this case we're working again with
the pendulum here I'm using a simulated
data set of the pendulum as opposed to
the actual raw video that I showed you
earlier so here we essentially want to
discover the pendulum equation from this
simulated video so we trained our
network using this data and in this case
we actually had to go to a second order
cyndy model um simply because the
pendulum equation is a second order
equation but in many cases the network
was able to actually discover that the
pendulum equation was the best
representation for this data set so here
I'm just showing the equation as
discovered by the network this is a
representation of the coefficient matrix
and then the attractor for the pendulum
in a handful of cases the network
actually discovered and said this sort
of simplified representation of the
pendulum so this just discovered a
linear equation instead of using the
sine term that is present in the
pendulum equation now this has slightly
different dynamics as you can see in the
attractor here and you actually if you
had look if you looked at the
performance of the cindy model in this
case you would actually you'd see that
the discovered linear model does not
have as good of a prediction of the
dynamics as this first model and so if
you're performing some sort of model
selection you'd be able to identify that
the pendulum occasion equation was the
best model for the dynamics but we just
thought it was interesting that in some
cases it was able it
discovering this reduce or the
simplified form of the pendulum equation
alright so in summary today I just told
you about our cindy auto-encoder methods
for discovering reduced coordinates and
associated person ammonia standing mixer
and high dimensional data so our
approach combined an auto using an auto
encoder for discovering reduced
coordinates with Cindy for discovering
parsimonious dynamics and if you'd like
more details feel free to check out the
full paper thank you